since the Gates Foundation was formed
back in 2000 by Microsoft co-founder
Bill Gates and his wife Melinda it has
paid more than forty five billion
dollars in grants supporting work in
more than 130 countries their work
addresses issues like vaccine delivery
family planning and emergency response
first on CBS this morning they're
revealing their 11th annual letter
highlighting they call it nine things
they didn't see coming
Bill and Melinda Gates our co-chairs and
trustees of the Gates Foundation we're
happy to say they're joining us a table
good to see you both so let's start with
this guy's because you've been wealthy
for a very long time whenever they say
Bill Gates and Melinda Gates they say
the world's richest people I wonder if
that moniker ever gets old but when did
you decide that listen we have all this
money we want to do something with it
Melinda well we were engaged to be
married and after we'd taken our first
trip to Africa actually a vacation we
were walking on the beach and we
committed at that point that we were
going to give the vast majority of the
resources for Microsoft back to society
just it was the right thing for us to do
bill you felt that - yeah we were
exploiting it and we've gotten more and
more engaged in it now it's our
full-time work so we were naive about
how to do it and how to have a big
impact but we knew that you know it was
amazing we have this fortune it was
gigantic we didn't think it would be
great to give lots of it to our children
and so and it became something that you
know we get to do together we're you
know partners in crime and you're
working very hard I want people to know
you're not sitting home you're both of
you were doing a lot of traveling you
just came back from Ethiopia bill but I
thought the letter was so fascinating
the thing that stuck out to me was about
data the importance of data I never
thought about that
yeah Lane why that's so important we
were surprised when we got into this
work having both come from the tech
sector that there was so little data
around philanthropy and we kept thinking
if we're gonna put another thousand
dollars into a project we have to know
whether the first ones worked whether
that projects worked and if we go call
in another government and so the data
can be sexist and data became very
important but that was the thing we
learned was that data that while we
think it's objective it's actually
sexist
we don't actually collect that much data
about women around
the world and so we don't know how to
make great investments on behalf of
women and so we've really highlighted
that issue in the last three years and
are working with our partners to collect
rate data event
well Africa has already come up twice in
this conversation oh you just came back
from Africa you talked about it being
the youngest continent and the real
growth potential there the the median
age is 18 in North America it is 35 why
is there potential that maybe the rest
of the world is not seeing and investing
in Africa and why is that so important
right now
well today Africa's only about 14% to
the world population but that's where
there's a large population growth and so
almost half the kids in the world we
will be born there by the end of the
century and so it's a very young
continent and the question of whether
those kids grow up with decent health
and decent education will determine
whether there's a lot of innovation and
they're stable and participating in the
world economy or if it's a source of
great instability and pandemics and so
investments we make now to partner with
Africa to help them out you know I think
can make a big difference and let me
piggyback on that one of the things you
argue and your letter is that national
that globalism can be a nationalist idea
explain that for people sure we know
that when you invest in people's health
and they start out healthy and they go
on to get a great education where they
live they'll grow up and thrive and
they'll participate in their own economy
and so there's huge potential there but
conversely if you don't they don't
thrive and then you get more instability
in the world less security disease we
know crosses borders we saw it with
Ebola so we need to be making those
investments so people can thrive where
they are and Bill let me ask you a
question about the domestic US you
learned something about anger by going
to prison tell us that story first
explain how the Bill and Melinda Gates
are sitting at prison what that was like
I was fascinated by that too John well
of course the US has more people in
prison than any other country and
understanding the stories of those
people and thinking about that in our
poverty work we there's
the Georgia prison that was so touching
then later I got a chance to in Chicago
meet with some young black men who were
in a counseling thing called becoming a
man and they super nice to me included
me in the session and it was a
discussion about anger and when's the
last time you got anger and how do you
channel that anger other times you don't
do that well I thought it was brilliant
and I was amazed how much that
counseling session was going to help put
those boys on the right track what was
your answer both of you to when was the
last time he became angry well I didn't
come up my I was talking about how
there's been more polio cases than we
hoped for this last year exact
experience last time for me was I I
would have said 'who's when I was in
Africa and I saw a baby die literally
dying needlessly on a warmer because the
mother hadn't made it to the health
clinic in time to give birth the village
didn't think she needed to go until too
late that made me angry the life we
could say race and sex play a big role
in this list in this letter this year
you talk about the mystery behind
premature births in particular among
african-american women in this country
african-american women are 49% more
likely to deliver their babies preterm
than white women one of the factors
could be racism explain that yes we
don't know all the factors but that is
on the rise as is maternal mortality in
the United States particularly under for
African American women and so we need to
look at all the factors is that the
health system is it the way they're
received there is it the stress in their
community is how we treat them is it
genetic we talk about selenium in here
we just don't know the answer but we
need to focus on that both in the US and
around the world around the world 10% of
babies are born prematurely and you know
if there's some thing in these puzzles
you've tried to solve over the last many
years that you've seen from outside the
United States
that you think hmm if we did things that
way in the United States and solving
these big seemingly insoluble problems
we might make some progress well the US
has by
for the world's most expensive health
care system and there are ways that we
could get better outcomes and be more
efficient we're more working in Africa
that total resources are like 1% per
person of what they are here in the US
and by focusing on vaccinations using
primary health care workers that don't
have to be doctors it's amazing what can
be done so that idea of task shifting
focusing on preventative disease that
that could work even in the US and the
thing that struck me guys was in the
letter you mentioned toilets you said
not sexy but toilets can save lives I'm
gonna leave that as a tease and say
people have to go to get the letter to
find out we as you point out bill they
haven't changed in a century and we all
need one thank you Bill and Melinda
Gates good to have you here